hello folks and welcome to
rational science why are we rational
uh well we're a little different than
all the others who are
irrational and uh
we can see the differences here we
always put them side by side
so we can compare what they do with what
we do
okay there is a scientific method that
these people
follow consists of observ observation
they do descriptions uh they do
predictions
and then they repeat the process over
and over again
and i call it the mathematical method
because all they come up with
are descriptions mathematical
descriptions math can
only describe it has no power no
authority
to explain anything in fact all the
explanations are
irrational coming from mathematical
physicists
and uh they just you know brush it aside
saying well first that's philosophy
that's uh handled on the other side of
campus
and uh then they also say well you know
that is um how mother nature or father
universe run their universe you know run
the universe but what happens
uh give me a second here
oh something happened there
uh that's the way they run the universe
and uh your logic does not coincide with
errors
but i'm concerned about father nature's
uh
logic i'm concerned about your logic you
know your logic is the one i'm
questioning now father nate
father universes and then there's the
issue of whether you represent
uh father universe mother nature does
your logic
match theirs do would they say the same
thing about your logic
okay so this is the issue so uh what do
we do
that's different well we this is our
scientific method that's one we propose
and it's a way of explaining
something to someone else objectively
okay so we have these three steps and
primarily the first two
uh we have the objects definitions and
the initial scene
that's where we start we have to name
the objects
in physics you can't do physics without
an object and then we have to explain to
you
a mechanism objectively okay
so yeah we end up with a different
universe
than the mathematicians have for the
last 400 years
they worked on it and they came up with
all kinds of nonsense black holes dark
matter
big bang creationism particle can be at
two places at once
all sorts of nonsense and they say well
we know it's irrational we don't
understand it either but that's how the
universe runs
no that's how the universe runs if you
explain it with particles
when you when you try to explain all
phenomena out there invisible phenomena
mediating it with invisible discrete
particles then you have a problem then
you end up with
irrational conclusions and what do we
propose instead well we propose
this we propose an interconnected
universe
all atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected they're all bound to each
other
and there we have uh the main
system at the bottom we have uh the
atoms doing their quantum jump
and when they do so they torque what we
call the
electromagnetic rope and that torsion is
what we call
light okay with this model we explain
gravity
as well we explain magnetism electricity
the whole works
and you can look it up in the
description you will find
a free book downloadable book pdf
illustrated books so that you can just
look at the pretty pictures
and get an idea of what the
rope model of light and gravity are all
about
and here's essentially the synthesis
okay and here it is
essentially everybody else does discrete
particles
and we do interconnected atoms we don't
interconnect them
with concepts such as energy mass and
time and that
sort of thing no we interconnect them
with physical
entities okay
okay um turns out that the
mathematicians
uh mathematical physicists the so-called
physicists
uh we call mathematicians mathematicians
is a better word
and uh they've branched out like i
explained the other day
into extinction and a very closely
related subject to extinction
is this issue of whether we are alone in
the universe
are we the only life form that has ever
arisen in the entire universe
with so many planets stars galaxies out
there
could we be the only life
out there would seem like the odds are
against that you would think that
there is some other civilization out
there
you know and then you got the issue
whether
it's just life something that as we say
moves against gravity
or if uh it's a little more it's uh
intelligent like humans are here that we
can
um reason
or are we we just looking for ants out
there
okay so that's the issue but the
question pops up in
as to whether the fact that we're alone
or that assumption or the thinking of
that
has anything to do with science does it
have to do anything with science
and so here uh here's a question okay
um is whether we
are alone in the universe a scientific
issue should we
discuss this in science at all okay
well you can make an assumption say say
uh we are the only planet with life
that's a good as an assumption if you're
going to use it for something if you're
going to explain something with that
okay but let's turn that around let's
say you want to theorize
that we are the only
civilization in the universe for example
or that
uh there are either very few or many
uh planets with life okay
uh or that we are alone maybe you want
to theorize we're alone because we
haven't heard from anyone else no one
has visited us
no one has sent messages to us
are those uh topics worthy of science do
they belong in science
my answer to that is no they do not have
anything to do with science why because
what those so-called theories are are to
uh demonstrate or explain
if if if that makes any sense if to
explain
existence it's like saying
you're going to explain the existence of
god okay
and you say okay how do you explain the
existence of god when god when
existence of god is an assumption
and these people might say well you know
uh you know the atheist might say well
god hasn't contacted me i've never seen
him so
he doesn't exist because of that and the
theists might say well you know i hear
voices every night before i go to sleep
and i pray and in the morning i get all
the all the
benefits of my prayer of my faith
and again what both are doing is one is
trying to prove the other one's
trying to unprove or disprove the
existence of god
and you know you don't prove or
existence
existence is something you assume you
make an assumption about something
which you think might exist and then use
it to explain something
and this is more or less the same thing
when you go in there and say
uh um you know let us assume there's
another civilization another world with
people out there that's an assumption
you can use that for whatever
okay you're going to for example you can
explain why
you found something you found an et here
on earth or
some uh thing that they left behind okay
so you can explain and say well let us
assume that there's another civilization
you can use it in adsense but you cannot
theorize
about the existence of another world
because you don't theorize about
existence
so that's an improper context for
science okay
the other thing is that you know if you
actually actively
search for life out there and say that
you're doing science scientific work
no that's a no-no that's why it's in
black now that
obviously is not science um doing
going out there and saying i'm going to
put a device to listen in
or i'm going to look for some gadget
that the martians left behind maybe in
the pyramid somewhere
that's not science okay that's uh
stamp collecting at best or at worst
okay so uh no uh let's make sure we
understand that
now um one of the fellows who got
involved
with uh this search for extraterrestrial
intelligence otherwise known as seti
that's the
uh organization um
his name is paul davies and
here's a quick summary of his bio okay
this is the fellow okay and
he said he's a math magician obviously
you're right he proposes qm and
gr that's why he's a math magician he's
going to explain
everything with magic voodoo magic
black magic okay and then he's going to
say well yeah we don't understand that
either but we've proven it
and here's the prediction and here's the
map equation
that's the way they they work with that
and your logic doesn't match
father universes okay fine he's got a
phd in mathematics
right university of college university
college in london
and he did some post-doc research
with fred hoyle for those of you who
know him steady state
universe right at cambridge and he works
specifically on quantum field theory in
curved space time
i got curved time how do you curve time
i mean you bend it you warp it
it shows that you know where he's coming
from this guy's not a scientist
he's not even a philosopher i don't know
what this is
this is nonsense this is just people
playing around with equations
and saying they're going to work time
that's their
physical interpretation when you
question them they backtrack and they
say well you know we don't understand it
either we can't warp time
but then you ask them why doesn't the
earth fly out of the solar system
well because we have this depression and
it's uh
warped time and that serves as a wall
for and prevents the earth from flying
out
that's the that's the physical
interpretation it's the
rolling ball the uh the little bead
going around the
bowling ball scenario you know that
weighs down the canvas
okay what are his main contributions to
mathematics
uh these are three things they're in the
wikipedia
says an observer accelerating through
empty space will be subject to a bath
of induced thermal radiation
these guys get prizes for the they
they get phds for this kind of stuff and
they get money
they get paid for this uh
uh apparently he explained something
about the fluctuations in the uh
what is it the cosmic background
radiation
whatever that is okay uh the first to
suggest that black holes evaporating via
the hawking effect
okay talked about that sometime in the
past uh lose mass as a result of a flux
of
negative energy streaming we have this
concept
this abstract concept called love i mean
energy and it's streaming
it flows into the hole from the
surrounding space so space
in mathematics is made out of
energy particles particles that combine
to form nothing and then they separate
to form
positive negative particles that come in
momentarily into the
world to make the equations come out
right then they immediately recombine go
back
so this what this guy worked on great
these guys get money for this okay
you're paying for these guys most of the
time you know through uh
government funds or grants or whatever
he teaches this nonsense at arizona
state university he's also taught
taught that other colleges and but the
subject of today is that one
uh he he's the chairman of the
post-detection
science and technology task group
i don't know about science again if he's
gonna be
searching for intelligence out there
he should really search for intelligence
inside his own
head you know but he's got a search for
intelligence out there uh you know
that's
that's not science okay so he'd like to
think of science but it's not
science is about explaining something
not about searching for
extraterrestrial aliens you know that's
fundamental
kind of stuff you know uh looking to see
if they find a ray gun
that they left in one of the uh
pharaoh's tombs or something you know
that's that's nonsense got nothing to do
with science
now this fellow you know you wouldn't
think much of him in fact you know i i
read about him for the first time in his
book
about time okay and uh shows you he's a
mathematical physicist he's a
mathematician why because that whole
book
not once does he define the word time i
mean it's
the book says about time okay
and he talks about time all the time in
the book
throughout he talks about greek time he
talks about
newtonian time galilean time talks about
relativistic
or einsteinian time not once
even in the glossary does he define the
word time
he just rants on about time like if you
knew what he was talking about
and he follows in the footsteps of
stephen hawking who wrote a brief
history of time
nowhere in that book do you find the
definition of the word time especially
not in the glossary
okay so these people they talk about
stuff they they never defined
and that's typical of mathematical
physics
okay so uh but you know you wouldn't pay
attention to this fellow if he had no
authority and it's important in
mathematical physics
to get authority that's the mathematical
method the mathematical method requires
that you have
authority no authority no one listens to
you
okay or less like me okay you gotta have
authority you gotta have some some
prizes okay
did this guy win any prizes oh man he
he's been in a lot of beauty contests
and uh
that's why you know i considered him a
um
a caricature of science caricature of
physics that's what he is that's what
all these
people who go you know and talk give
talks
based on their authority based on the
fact that they said oh i studied
mathematical physics so what you know
nothing about physics you can't tell me
a single can't give me a single
explanation
how a magnet attracts another uh why the
pen falls to the floor you can't give me
a single
rational explanation what do you tell me
you say a particle can be at two places
at once
and that time is warped
and then they say yeah we don't
understand it either yeah no kidding
so yeah this uh won a lot of um a beauty
contest and um you can see there he's
got a lot of olympic gold medals uh
jumped over the line etc you know uh
so yeah he's he's full of um medals
but see he doesn't have as many medals
as a guy like stephen hawking
okay he died a couple years ago he's
even hogging the guy in a wheelchair
okay now hawking you know outranks him
because you know he he at least got a
uh medal the wolf medal okay
and you know i don't know about wolf
metal because uh
you know uh yeah he he did a lot of
howling
about what he found and what he
discovered etc especially about black
holes he's the guy who made him famous
together with
roger penrose okay um
i think these people should change their
name should call it the uh rooster
foundation
you know uh i mean they're gonna crow
i would put a rooster that's me you know
i mean i don't know
i guess uh wolf would also satisfy that
okay but yeah these guys just crow a lot
about stuff that
they never explained okay and they get
all these prizes and that's how they get
authority
once they have authority hey man you
know you got a medal for knowledge
for intelligence now you can you know
put your thumb on
any ant down there that tries to
challenge you
that's what it's all about it's a good
old boy's uh club
okay but davey's you know he
he doesn't have as many medals as
hawking and he's missing the most
important one
which is the cmb i mean you know and
again it's very important to consider
all these
things because they work on the basis of
authority that's what it's all about
authority authority authority they can't
explain
anything but they shove it down your
throat through authority saying hey you
know i got a degree from cranbridge
and you tell them well i've only got a
high school degree but i think
what you're saying is irrational yeah
but i outrank you
and this is what gives them rank but see
uh
neither of these two guys like you know
lawrence over arabia i mean he did
something for the british empire he went
out there to the middle east
killed a bunch of people you know so he
expanded the empire he never got a medal
so
i can't imagine uh you know paul davies
getting a medal
but he got one for for from the
templeton foundation
and uh that's worth a million bucks at
least
so you know you may laugh at these guys
but they're laughing all the way to the
bank
okay they do make a lot of money you
know selling all this nonsense
and you know templeton foundation what
does it do it tries to merge
science with religion they're saying you
know
there's a fine line between them there's
no difference
it's not a cut and dry difference like
we put it in rational science you're
either rational you're
irrational you're irrational or
supernatural
you're doing religion and if you believe
especially if you believe
if you talk about opinions if you're
going to prove if you're going to
present evidence
you're going to talk about knowledge
then you're talking about religion
in science we don't do that in science
we explain objectively so that you
understand
what you believe whether you agree or
not is irrelevant to science
you can do that at home in your own time
science is only about explaining
these people don't explain all they do
is try to convince you
that's why they're religious fanatics
okay and that's what mathematical
physics has become
and mathematical physics to these people
is a synonym of science
and a scientific method okay
uh this fellow wrote several books
and here's a a list of them uh
again you know uh maybe the last 10
books he wrote he's
written more than this and again you can
see about time there number two
and the ones i'm concerned about today
are are we alone
and another one in 2010 the eerie
silence
why because he talks about whether
there's life out there in the universe
he analyzes that
okay and uh so
uh what does he say well here's uh
here's a
uh very quick uh synthesis
of some of the issues maybe the most
important issues he touches upon
in his book okay and here it is
fellow says the following he says uh one
of the issues right
if we can make life in a lab it would
not show that life is easy to make by
mother nature out there these are my
words but
this is what he meant okay so you know
the fact that we can do an experiment
like
they did in the 1950s uh urian
miller where they put some
methane and other carbon compounds i
believe they give it a
shot of electricity and they created
amino acids
and they said well you know there's a
step there and it's a good experiment
because if you can produce amino acids
which is the foundation
of or one of the stepping stones one of
the missing links
of life well you got a good chance of
um of giving an explanation because
it's an important point okay to be able
to do that
so in that sense it's okay but even if
some some
bug would have crawled out of the flask
he's saying well does that really
tell us anything about whether mother
nature did it the same
way or or whether there is life out
there somewhere else
maybe this was a unique experience here
on earth in the entire universe
okay so we still don't know anything
because we only have one data point and
that's earth
okay uh he said uh he asked could life
have restarted many times on earth
and this is an interesting point because
you know conceivably right
um as far as we know we we trace
life here on earth at least the the
crawling life the one in the seas and
upwards
uh to the cambrian pre-cambrian you're
talking about 600 million years ago
and the question is you know if the
earth has been around for a little more
like say 4 billion or 5 billion years
well then uh maybe life started and
ended many times throughout that period
of time
could have happened right and
under the rope model well we have uh
an argument that even favors that to
some degree so let's put the argument
the argument
is that the earth was not made by the
flowing gases that made the sun
but it was used to be a star and it lost
its uh
outer shells and it became
a planet and that's why our planet
the earth is both round roundish
you can only produce that amount of
roundish roundness
uh by being a star and it also
differentiated
so we like the other theory better and
again
you know the uh the theory that uh the
earth used to be a star
and not that it was condensed uh through
the
nebular hypothesis uh version
that today is prime uh prevalent in
mathematical physics okay
so we're saying that the earth used to
be a star
what does that mean well let's assume
that the
5 billion year old sun is true that's
the
the age given to our son
if the sun is only 5 billion years old
that swirling mass of gases that
condense to form the sun
let's let's concede that okay um
then the way what we're saying is yeah
maybe the sun condensed that way but not
the rocky planets the rocky planets used
to be stars as well they condensed
uh they turned into these uh black
dwarves as they're known
and it was captured by the sun
and the rolling mass of gas and created
the solar system
so the earth was there before the sun
condensed into
this little star that we have and it
gives us
uh heat and light okay that's that's our
version
but if that's the case you know the
earth
was only captured about four or five
billion years ago
and assume we're again assuming that
this these are the numbers these are
correct numbers
so if we've been around for four or five
billion years ago
could life have started over and over
and over again
well i think that depends a lot on the
sun also how old
how how long or what the process of the
sun was
for it to condense begin to radiate
enough heat and light that would allow
for light to come on earth
and i think that would have been a long
process so my
guess at least my guess my assumption is
that the one that i usually follow
is that no we won't find
nowhere on earth that there was a
previous civilization
you know and that left something out
there maybe they went to the moon maybe
they went to mars maybe we go to the
moon we find you know
some artifact that they left i don't
think that's gonna happen
i think um life started only once on
earth and it may have started maybe
again like 600 million years ago
and before that the sun
was in the process of condensing and
creating the amount
the right conditions for earth to have
life
okay so that's that's my take on that so
i don't think there was
um a um
a previous civilization here on earth
okay
um next point is that uh he says um
there could be other civilizations that
do some astro engineering you know some
advanced alien
technology and they would maybe
have like a radio beacon out there like
a lighthouse you know
scouting for life around the uh their
region or around the galaxy right and
you know all we have to do is wave our
hands and they'll see us maybe you know
that sort of thing
we got to make some noise so that they
can pick it up
and this comes uh pretty much close to
another subject which is uh this which
is the
kardashev scale which gives us an idea
how we can detect them
okay and it goes more or less like this
you have three
levels of um civilizations
and was created by this fellow russian
guy kardashev
and he said not kardashian by the way
and
um he says it it depends on how much
energy they use
you can or how much energy they were
able to conquer
to master okay and here you have 10 to
the 16 watts
and that would be at the planetary level
when you get to 10 to the 26 watts well
you're talking about the stellar level
that means
we conquer the entire solar system and
we
are able to mine all the energy
in our solar system when you get to 10
to the 36 watts
well now you're talking about the
galactic level okay
you're saying okay now we've conquered
the entire galaxy we've got our
ships flying back and forth from one
star to another
i suppose uh star trek like okay
and what this gives us an idea
or at least all these people right
especially the people at seti
to which paul davies belongs okay
is that how we can detect another
civilization all we got to look for
is stuff at the maybe stellar level
or hopefully at the galactic level that
detects something say oh
here's a civilization that has conquered
the galaxy
and say they they've already um
are able to mine all the energy of the
galaxy and they do
stuff that we cannot even imagine and so
we would be able to see something like
that and say oh jesus this
this is not uh natural this is
artificial
someone has doctored all this stuff and
now we can see it and say there is
another civilization out there
so that's one of the ways they propose
detecting
um another civilization
uh but then there's the issue that he
brings up
fermi's paradox you know uh how come no
one has contacted us
and yeah you have people like fondonica
out there that say yeah they have been
here and they left
and otherwise we wouldn't have the
pyramids or who knows what you know
these
ancient uh civilizations that had all
this
knowledge and technology and we lost it
over time and now all we can do is just
dig into the runes and see if we can
find the ray gun or the bullet or
whatever they left behind you know
um have they been here uh
i say flatly no they've never been here
so
those people who search for
you know ets here on earth oh man
poor people
he talks about colonizing mars
okay and again we become the martians
and that way in a way
it's like saying uh yeah see uh
when the marxians wake up one day they
say hey you know there are earth things
yeah no kidding we
we we colonized you guys you know that
sort of thing
and uh there are people who have talked
a lot and do things about this
issue uh first one was this fellow um
von braun okay vernon form brown an ss
officer who was recruited by the
americans and developed the
uh rocketry for the military
and vernon reformed brown he had i think
he had a book uh in 1950s
early 1950s and uh he suggested you know
he came up with a plan to colonize mar
to
to go to to mars you know and he already
had developed that he was
developing rockets he said hey we can
take a rocket
and take not only to the moon we can
take it to mars okay and he knew that
mars we could put a colony there an
artificial colony
you know so he was already with that and
today we have people like elon musk
he's working on that project heavily you
know trying to get
humans to mars and my only question is
for what
why are we sending humans to mars what
do we plan to
do uh trade with mars
bananas you know they produce potatoes
and we trade bananas for
potatoes is that why we're going to have
a colony on mars
will those people ever come back why
would we
do a one-way trip to mars and
thus we could just stay there i mean
it's like paying for someone else to
have fun
assuming you know they have fun out
there okay
or are we going out there just to see
the world to have a little vacation
say you know i've been to mars a week
and now i came back
is that what mars is for i mean
are we going to evacuate the earth maybe
all the prisons and
put them out there and say hey all the
prisoners go to mars now
pinot colony like the british did with
australia
guyanas and so on yeah the question is
why why would we go to mars
and so
i don't know even if mars is ever going
to happen but if it does happen
maybe the first trip will be with robots
some exploration of some kind just to
see if we can get there
and meanwhile they're going to prepare
some astronauts
whether we're ever going to make it i
don't know i think that maybe the
world humans will become extinct very
soon
and i'm not sure if they're going to
beat that deadline okay
that's my take on that um
have uh other uh
uh civilizations uh sent a bottle
uh you know a message in a bottle you
know like when you get stuck on an
island you send a message in a bottle
arrives in california and they know to
pick you up over there in the pacific
somewhere
uh he's suggesting that maybe
they left something in the genome maybe
maybe by looking
casually through some thousands or
gazillions of
um dnas
or chromosomes or whatever we find
some code say oh oh that this wasn't
mother nature this had to be
from some alien so that's one of the
messages in the bottle he suggests
we could look for you know spend our
time looking for
and uh the one that struck me the most
is really the last one
civilizations that made it to the future
he just mentions that in passing like
saying you know
a lot of civilizations may die like carl
sagan
suggested uh in fact i mentioned that
some time back
and the question is how many of those
surpass their infighting
killing each other becoming extinct how
many surpass that moment are able to
get beyond that point and they all
become friends you know
on on their planet you know the blacks
with the whites and the browns and the
yellow
all these races come together all the
religions come together the
muslim kisses the christian and so on
you know they all finally leave all
their differences
aside and they work towards the future
and they create this
great civilization that allows them to
expand further maybe to other star
systems
and maybe even throughout the galaxy and
so that is uh
really the one that struck me here you
have his
take on that a second take that he gives
he says looking for et's is like looking
into our own future
okay if there are many civilizations
that have made it through there are
many crisis many crisis okay
and like saying that's petty stuff you
know infighting
and have gone on to a glorious future
well then we see in the sky trajectory
of the
future of humanity searching for them
out there
is searching for ourselves
okay you see where he's going with us so
all these people uh
mathematicians like carl sagan and uh
good old davies here will include
hawking in there as well all these
people thought in the same way
and they're all thinking you know if
humanity doesn't destroy
itself that's that's their key issue
in other words the only way man can
become extinct in the minds of these
people
is if we kill ourselves we commit
suicide by
killing each other in fighting more or
less like the t-rex did at the end you
know they killed each other
when food ran out so they had to kill
each other they had to do cannibalism
because there was nothing left as food
are we gonna do something similar uh
here we're gonna eat each other are we
gonna
shake hands kiss each other work
together in
uh cooperation you know and
build the future is that how uh humanity
is going to progress in the future
well one of the issues that you would
think these people analyze
is you know uh what are the
possibilities
of life existing out there to begin with
before you start searching for it is
there any possibility
of there being life out there and yeah
they did
analyze that and he analyzes that in
quite a bit of detail it's known as the
drake equation
okay here's the drake equation for those
of you who are not familiar with
it and goes something like this he says
um what are the number of
technologically advanced civilizations
in the milky way galaxy this is just a
milky way okay just one galaxy here
and so uh they go into uh
all these different groups they study
out there and they try to figure out
what's out there what
what they can see what they can measure
okay
and uh the first factor there is the
rate of formation of stars in the galaxy
well the university of calgary has come
up with a number okay
so there are roughly 150 billion stars
born per year in the entire universe
150 billion per year
this corresponds to about 400 million
stars born
per day so that's a lot of stars how
many of those belong to our galaxy well
if if i heard davies correctly i think
he said
seven okay seven stars per year on the
average
okay let's that's good so we have a
number
uh second point is fraction of those
stars with planetary systems
how many of those have planets and says
at least one in six stars has an
earth-sized planet according to nasa
okay so the nasa folks they said there's
at least one in six stars about 16
percent
of them that they've seen out there they
say has at least one earth-sized planet
okay we have a second number uh the next
one is the number of planets
per solar system with an environment
suitable for life
and they determine this by looking at
whether it's got oxygen whether it's got
some kind of uh atmosphere whether it's
got water
those kind of things and berkeley and
uh one study it came in 2013 i think
it's the only study really
says the fraction of stars with
earth-like planets is about 22 percent
plus or minus eight percent okay so they
have a
wedded spread there okay but you can see
i stopped at the green line
anything on the left side of the green
line tells you something about
that we can determine objectively okay
more or less objectively we can look out
there and find out
okay this planet has this this planet
has that this star has this
and we can more or less draw some
conclusions from the
uh measurements that we make those are
objective you could say okay
or more or less objective what happens
on the right hand side of that green
line which i've
outlined in green is you got these other
four factors in the drake equation
and these are all speculative okay you
see the fraction of suitable planets on
which life
actually appears okay that's we have no
idea
fraction of life-bearing planets on
which intelligent life
emerges and i guess intelligent life
they refer to human-like intelligence at
least
right so anything that is not us
uh does not count that means there is a
small fraction
okay of the planets which actually where
life appears okay
then we have two more factors and those
are the ones that also interest me
fractional civilizations that develop a
technology that releases
detectable signs uh of their existence
into space
and the length of time such
civilizations release detectable signals
into space okay why did i
circle them or draw them in in red
well i have my own equation i'll share
it with you today
okay this is my equation okay
here it is for those who want to see it
i multiply all this times zero
okay all those factors times zero for uh
uh civilizations that we can contact
okay or that can contact us
that's that's my equation so i'm not
concerned about
how many civilizations out there
technologically advanced civilizations
are out there
i'm concerned about how many of those we
can contact or can contact us
and whether it's worth even doing
anything i'm saying it's zero
okay say bill you're a little
pessimistic
today i drank too much beer so i guess
i'm a little pessimistic
uh let me tell you why i'm not
pessimistic it's
called realistic let's be realistic
okay and here's the realism that i
propose
for that zero okay here it is
okay this is my bill gate equation
why there is no possibility of ever
contacting or receiving messages from
another world
okay that's what my equation has to do
with the curve of life of an intelligent
species such as man is geologically
short very small window of opportunity
okay uh the our doomsday clock you know
we talk about the doomsday clock the
other day okay
shows that technology necessary to
communicate with other worlds develops
in the last minute
we've only had and i'll be very uh
generous we've had 200 years of
communicating technology i mean i'm not
talking about smoke signals
from the indians or maybe a drum now i'm
talking about
you know mastering electricity
the telegraph that kind of thing and i'm
including those within this
okay so i'll give it 200 years to be on
the safe side
that should cover all the technology
that we have
invented regarding transmission and
reception
okay radios tvs they were they're only
100 years old
okay okay what's the problem with that
well we're close to doom
and so that gives us an idea that we
only have
100 to 200 years that's all that
humanity
has to transmit and receive that's a
very small geological window
right there and of course if like i say
we're about to become extinct
very very soon that's it that's all the
time
that's the entire span that's the entire
range
okay and considering you know when you
talk about
uh the sun being there five billion
years a hundred years is not too much
it's not even tenth
we're talking about it's very very small
window there it takes thousands of years
for most stars at least right for light
to reach planets inhabited
within with human level intelligence
and you know we're staggered also the
next point there planets with human
human towns that's what they call it the
cia human
are staggered in time in other words
here we are
we had our 200 years of glory right our
golden age where we have all this
technology and
internet and all that stuff it's great
stuff we can also see all the history in
the past say oh look what happened to
napoleon and this guy
they don't know what happened to us but
we know what happened to them you know
so
there's a lot of advantage of this day
and age
right in that sense at least right but
uh assuming we've we're only going to
live 200 years with this technology
of transmitting and receiving imagine
another planet yeah they might have
life they might have even developed
intelligent life maybe intelligent life
similar to ours
evolved there well uh
maybe they're a hundred years behind us
and so when we go
out they come in they say oh let's look
for life out there let's see if we can
find oh there's a planet
earth it's got water it's got er it's
got oxygen
maybe there's life on that plant let's
send a message see if we receive
a message in a bottle and it turns out
we're all dead here
so we can't send anything then there's
the issue of
signals you know uh under the rope model
you send them through the
electromagnetic ropes
but what happens with any rope well from
the point where it's on the wall
outwards
the links become longer
it's known as the redshift so all this
stuff about you know the universe flying
apart well maybe there's a different
take on that maybe that redshift is a
a sim uh
evidence right of something else of
just light the rope
uh becoming longer and longer the links
becoming longer and longer and longer
what does that mean it means lower and
lower
frequency and we put that into
a signal that is sent out by the time it
reaches
alpha centauri which is only four light
years away
the other one one that is thousands and
thousands or millions
of light years away uh
i don't think much is going to reach
them
maybe a faint light i mean
how much light do we receive from
between the objects we can see in the
in the sky you know that black stuff we
call space
there's there's stars there and there
are uh planets there
and we don't receive the light from
those because they're just too far away
and between them and us light
what happens to the light that they emit
well it eventually
dwindles into longer links
and so it fizzles away and so if we send
light out and
send messages out or receive message try
to receive messages
we're going to encounter also the
dilution of the signal
so that in a nutshell is what i suggest
that
we're wasting our time because it turns
out that people like
paul davies they ask for donations to
help set the
look for intelligence out there
and i think these people are dreamers
they watch too many
too many uh star trek movies or maybe
twilight zone outer limits
episodes they're kidding themselves
not only we will not find anything out
there because
the lifespan of intelligence is too
short
and even shorter is the lifespan of
intelligence which
developed technology to transmit and
receive
it's it's not even a drop in the ocean
and so that's one issue the other one is
again the signal gets diluted
they're too far away and then they're
staggered in time
that in a nutshell is my five cents
worth